foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Monday
they're also so beautiful so beautiful
talking to myself
so it's bagpipes versus crack pipes
Hunter Biden has finally put some pants
on and is now suing Delaware repair shop
owner John Paul Mack Isaac what happened
to George and Ringo
names
it's being sued for invasion of privacy
yes Hunter is suing him for invasion of
privacy
Hunter who's been nude who's been seen
nude by more people than the statue of
David
honestly in the last year I've seen this
guy's genitals more times than his
primary care physician and I would get
that checked out
he's invaded my privacy the privacy of
my own nightmares as you know Mr Mac
Isaac claimed Hunter dropped off a
laptop for repair in April 2019 and then
never came back Mac Isaac even has an
invoice with Hunter's signature although
those pages are stuck together
foreign
but for once Hunter signed on a line
instead of snorting it
the laptop contained not only salacious
photos and videos of the naughtiest
little Biden cavorting with hookers and
crack but also copious evidence of the
Biden family's massive International
corruption specifically the family
received over a million bucks from
accounts linked to Hunter's Chinese
business associates
and finally even CNN admits that you
know on a certain level just as a
layperson you hear this and it doesn't
sound good on a certain level just as a
sound good there's a guy whose name is
uh John Robinson Walker he gets three
million dollars from a Chinese based
company and proceeds to wire it out to a
bunch of people named Biden one of whom
is Hunter Biden another one is a company
that belongs to the president's brother
James Biden and another amount of money
to Beau Biden's uh Widow Hallie so again
from a lay person that doesn't look good
she's a lay person she's the layperson
twice of course the Biden 2020 campaign
in every liberal journalist in the world
insisted without evidence that the
laptop's contents were Russian disinfo
when really the only thing Russian on
that laptop were probably the hookers
Hunter Biden this laptop that
intelligence officials have warned or is
likely Russian disinformation are tied
to an ongoing Russian disinformation
effort could actually be part of
Russia's latest and very massive
disinformation campaign U.S authorities
are seeking if those emails we just
talked about are connected to an ongoing
Russian disinformation effort it's sort
of a a crazy quilt at this point uh
which has all the Hallmarks of of
Russian disinformation oh a crazy quilt
with all the Hallmarks sounds like
something Don Lemon wears on spring
break
Lane was ridiculous to begin with
what was the superior the theory
supposed to be anyway that Putin set up
a fake computer repair shop in
Wilmington
just on the remote chance that a decade
later a presidential candidate's
crackhead son would stumble inside and
abandon a bunch of Juicy evidence that
might swing a presidential election that
conspiracy theory is as thin as Joe's
hair
on his head
but also Hunter wouldn't Sue anybody for
violating his privacy if it's fake
evidence planted by the ruskies right
and now all the news outlets that push
the Russian disinfo liar just pretending
they never made that claim which
suggests that Joe's dementia was always
more contagious than covid
foreign
so you know what I've noticed lately we
were right about everything and by we I
mean me also you if you agree with me if
you don't go screw yourself
let's go over a few other stories we
nailed that the rest of the media didn't
for example Tick Tock is indeed spying
on us for the Chinese government
[Music]
I wouldn't applaud that
now I'm not on Tick Tock for obvious
reasons first I'm not a 14 year old girl
yet
still waiting for the puberty blockers
but if I were the Chinese government
would be doing to me what they're doing
to other American girls messing with
their heads but also I don't want the
Chinese Communist Party watching me
while I'm alone in my apartment I mean
what if Taylor Swift realizes I did keep
her sweatshirt
but that Tricom spy app has rapidly
become an essential part of American
life or at least Gretchen whitmer's
advisors think so these are my ladies
[Music]
little Susie Brianna you know why we
call it Brianna right now yeah it's a
long story Shaniqua Helga this Kitty
Genie I dream of that well you know
that's one way to keep the kidnappers at
Bay
foreign
s love their Tick Tock and they're
distraught that the White House might
ban it because now Joe finally admitting
that China is our enemy they planted a
spy on every cell phone in America and
it's not racist now to notice that just
the name of the app alone kind of gave
it away Tick Tock as in time is running
out on your world dominance America
speaking of China kova 19 yes was a lab
League not too long ago you weren't even
allowed to speculate that the virus was
made by human hands especially the tiny
ones of Anthony fauci
when he when he wasn't practicing his
autograph
a fairly large group of very well
respected evolutionary virologists have
come to the conclusion not definitively
by any means but feeling that it is much
more likely that it is a natural
occurrence from an animal to a human
however since it hasn't been
definitively proven we've got to keep a
completely open mind
oh okay so now it's okay to have an open
mind because remember it wasn't before
you know it was bat soup or you're a
racist
so there's an entire multi-billion
dollar industry devoted to missing
everything we say and those accusing us
follow a pattern they first Define our
opinions as not worthy of debate using
disinformation as a smear and if that
doesn't work they call it hate speech
but we were right they pretend they're
the ones who are right all along instead
it's as if they're so dumb they think
all they have to do is repeat that's not
true
those are the facts
it's like she's reading her old bigoted
blog posts to her gay friends
real media has a huge blind spot it's
called the truth and no matter how many
times they get it wrong and try to
silence us for saying so they still
expect us to trust them so once in a
while it feels nice to bask and being
proven right if Vindication were
chocolate cake I'd look like this guy
[Applause]
show Guy Benson
I think we use that
after the Ford Mustang she's Michigan's
favorite two-door
Airlines try to charge him for the bags
under his eyes comedian Jim rumor
[Applause]
light wire Y and barely trying to keep
it together Fox News contribute her cat
too
guy thank you for taking a break from
reading of children's books to uh
orphans doesn't he look like you you
should be reading like a little book
about The Little Engine That Could Oh I
thought that was a drag joke
is how right I am everything and maybe
that's why I am your role model
you are inspirational Greg no one's ever
doubted that so this new allegation
about the documents and now even more
bidens we're getting money I guess from
China I saw the president was asked
about this over the weekend and he stood
there and he was confused and then they
explained it to him and then he put on
this little grin and he said that's not
true sort of like Joy Reid actually
that's not true that was this whole
rebuttal and I've been thinking about
this and I believe him oh really I
believe him his word is abiding means a
lot to me Greg and he's told us nothing
but the truth about this stuff so far
right he told Peter Ducey two summers
ago that he knew nothing about any of
the foreign business dealings of his son
that's obviously correct uh he told us
that the laptop was Russian
disinformation I mean yes he's right
again so he's in my mind he's three for
three and he's basically
like George Washington reincarnate and I
believe him fantastic
so basically you're saying yes Greg I'm
right on everything yes yeah thank you
that's all I need to see upshot thank
you
tutor welcome to the show I wish you
weren't here and instead Governor I
agree with you on that yeah so you're
right yeah there you go see see that's
how it works see how that works so I'm
seated here and you're over there and
that dad's sweater
where do you see the hunter buying thing
going is this something where like I
sometimes I wonder if we're just
mirroring what they did with Trump or
you just keep saying that walls are
closing in the walls are closing in they
never close in no I see this I see a lot
of feminists rising up because we see
this coming out and of course the woman
gets paid the least yes I mean give me a
break yes like with 30 grand yeah I know
30 grand to sleep with Hunter what yeah
if it were yes exactly that was all it
was 30 grand that's how much you paid
Holly Biden that's what that's what I
read right right right I think that I
think Stormy Daniels got like 10 times
that right
see
if you're going to compare them at least
Trump's a big spender
here's the thing okay we're talking
about all these transactions what's
missing in the entire story is who paid
taxes like is that the easiest way to
figure this stuff out if like if there
was a million bucks they split it three
ways the check comes in they have to pay
taxes on it that's right but you know
the the Chinese probably paid the taxes
for them I mean they're they're
welcoming them in right now you know
just pay the taxes for us yeah I don't
know man Jim how you doing I'm doing
good yeah yeah you look happy I am happy
you're always happy story cracks me up
yeah what makes you laugh about well
just just the whole pitch how did it get
from yeah no I know there's hookers on
there I know I know I may some of them
may have been underage I know I might
have sold some documents like I'm
selling missiles but it's private
doesn't that mean anything anymore
yeah I mean God dead animals was private
yes there's people tied up in the trunk
but it's private
come on
yeah it's amazing that before I mean it
was interesting when it first came out
it was like he was the one who didn't
say anything but he's always lost
and there's a
that's a pretty good sorry I was much
jealous aren't you jealous
I like or I'm just jealous that there's
a there's a family member in your
somebody's family that makes money rain
that makes it rain for you like he's
just out getting wouldn't you like a
sibling like that he's just mil just
there's one million
almost literally oh I'm in Ukraine oh
I'm in China board I don't know why any
of this this is amazing thanks Dad
I just want to point out to the
producers that he's actually imitating
milking milk now yes this is milking
Captain he was not doing a video
that's amazing you people even know what
I'm talking about
they're not even supposed to laugh at
that stuff supposed to go over your head
you guys are sick they are sick
[Applause]
pretty funny when they walk out as the
Hannity audience walks it
[Laughter]
it's like that scene in The Poseidon
Adventure where they walk past each
other
so cat you know he
actually are right nobody gives us
credit so I have to do this all the time
are you happy that I get to say that I'm
right all the time now that I'm being
Vindicated except for the times when
you're not right I say I'm wrong a lot
yeah you do yeah not here though yeah
uh yeah I just it would ex makes it more
irritating is like the this family this
Biden family they love they love being
rich yeah and they love getting more
rich but then they also don't want me to
ever get rich yeah like oh like I don't
I'm making money through going to work
at a job yeah like the normal way and
they're like well actually you need to
give me your fair share of that money
you earned I'm like what the you
have and you're doing all this and it's
like China the Saudi government and all
these different things and it's like
you're doing all this Shady stuff
because you love being rich and yet
there's no such thing as your fair share
of my money that I am receiving earning
in the legal normal way and also
foreign
like none of us here have full proof
investment strategies like we lose money
they don't like we're like we're only
privy to certain kinds of Investments
like the stock market which terrifies me
I've never I invested in stupid stuff
but this is like this is a thousand
percent uh return in fact there is no
return because you're not putting any
money in it's just coming to you here's
the foolproof solution Greg change your
last name to Biden yeah nothing Biden
exclamation point starting tomorrow and
the money just Flows In This Is Why I'm
not having kids I always say no kids
gonna sponge off my last name if I
couldn't sponge if I could not sponge
off of Gutfeld right no kids gonna
sponge off me but rather than the same
thing
rather than being the big guy though you
would be the little guy
[Applause]
it was unnecessary we had a nice segment
everybody was getting along
we have new we have a new panelist here
and then he comes on here and has to
insult the host in front of a new guest
I'm okay with it but we're going to talk
about it after the show and you know
where you'll come after my sweater yeah
I'm gonna fire back yes by the way
you're wearing it inside out okay hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else